If a star explodes in a distant galaxy and
no one’s around to hear it, does it make
a sound?
No!
But it DOES generate a truckload of gravitational
waves!
(We think.)
Hi!
I’m Ian O’Neill, space producer for Discovery
News, and I wanted to take you on a brief
voyage into what links some of the craziest
cosmic events we know about.
I’m talking about supernovas, black hole
mergers, neutron star collisions, orbiting
white dwarfs and even the biggest bang of
them all… the Big Bang!
So what exactly connects them all?
That’d be gravitational waves; and if you’ve
been paying attention these last few months,
you’ll know that these wiggles in spacetime
have been insanely hard to find.
Astronomers using the BICEP2 telescope located
in the South Pole THOUGHT they’d identified
primordial gravitational waves embedded in
the Cosmic Microwave Background radiation
last year.
Unfortunately, it seems that these signals
may have just been noise.
But that doesn’t mean it’s curtains for
the search for gravitational waves and gravitational
wave detectors, not by a long shot.
Rather than seeking out ancient gravitational
waves created by the Big Bang, the Laser Interferometer
Gravitational-Wave Observatory -- or LIGO
-- is ACTIVELY looking for gravitational waves
passing through Earth right this second!
These waves were predicted by Einstein and
are a product of his famous theory of general
relativity.
In a nutshell, Einstein’s equations predicted
that should a massive object like a black
hole or neutron star suddenly accelerate,
decelerate or collide, energy will be lost.
But in these cosmic scenarios, energy is lost
through powerful ripples in spacetime -- much
like the ripples that race across the surface
of a pond after a pebble hits the water.
Although there is strong indirect evidence
of their existence, we have yet to spot them
directly.
This is where LIGO comes in.
LIGO consists of two stations on opposite
sides of the United States, and it uses a
highly sensitive method called interferometry
to detect the TINY effect a propagating gravitational
wave will have on spacetime.
As gravitational waves wash THROUGH the Earth
-- yes, I said THROUGH, as in through US!
-- there is the tiniest of tiny shrinkage
or expansion in local spacetime.
But for LIGO, which has recently undergone
an upgrade, such a minuscule spacetime warping
SHOULD be detectable and, since 2002, the
project has been on the lookout.
This thing is so sensitive that it is probing
distances on the smallest scales thought to
exist in spacetime -- it should be able to
detect a distance change of 10,000th the width
of a proton.
Although LIGO has yet to see a definitive
signal, it is using a process of elimination,
ruling out where these waves AREN’T and
physicists are confident they are closing
in on the first detection in the coming years.
By firing a split laser down LIGO’s two
perpendicular 4 kilometer-long L-shaped tunnels
and bouncing those beams many times, an interferometer
can compare the two beams and detect any slight
shifts in frequency.
This tiny shift could represent the passage
of a gravitational wave.
Should that wave be detected by both LIGO
locations, the source of the wave could be
derived and we could see the beginning of
a new era of gravitational wave astronomy.
Although the LIGO instrumentation uses a complex
system of shock absorbers, magnetic fields
and sophisticated filters to drown out any
outside interference, the detector is so sensitive
that it can still pick up false signals from
strong winds or passing vehicles, only making
this search for a gravitational wave in the
proverbial haystack of noise even harder.
Fortunately this epic quest on the frontier
of scientific discovery isn’t short of some
great physics minds.
Students from Caltech recently created a colorful
visualization to connect known interference
events with their corresponding signal detected
by LIGO, thus eliminating terrestrial noise
from the continuing search for extraterrestrial
sources of gravitational waves.
But will this be enough to finally tease this
tiny wobble out of the tangled, noisy mess
of spacetime?
Let us know what you think in the comments
below, and if you’re interested in other
cosmic peculiarities, check out my video about
a weird cold spot
in the universe and what it might mean